I'M GREG GUTFELD, KENNEDY,
JESSE WATTERS AND JUAN
WILLIAMS.
THIS IS THE FIVE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PUTTING
AMERICA FIRST FRONT AND
CENTER DURING A ROUSING
COMMENCEMENT ADDRESS AT THE
U.S. NAVAL ACADEMY
GRADUATION.
THIS COMES AS MORE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS UNFOLD OVER THE
NORTH KOREA SUMMIT.
BUT, BEFORE WE GET TO THAT
LET'S HEAR THE PRESIDENT'S
MESSAGE TO THE CLASS OF 2018
STRESSING THE IMPORTANCE OF
OUR MILITARY'S MIGHT.
>> WE ARE WITNESSING THE
GREAT REAWAKENING OF THE
AMERICAN SPIRIT AND OF
AMERICAN MIGHT.
WE HAVE REDISCOVERED OUR
IDENTITY.
REGAINED OUR STRIDE.
AND WE ARE PROUD AGAIN.
YES, THEY ARE RESPECTING US
AGAIN.
YES, AMERICA IS BACK.
THE BEST WAY TO PREVENT WAR
IS TO BE FULLY PREPARED FOR
WAR.
IF A FIGHT MUST COME, THERE
IS NO OTHER ALTERNATIVE.
VICTORY, WINNING, BEAUTIFUL
WORDS.
TO THE CLASS OF 2018, I DO
SAY STRIFE FOR
SAY STRIVE FOR EXCELLENCE.
LIVE FOR ADVENTURE, DREAM
BIG, PUSH FURTHER, SAIL
FASTER.
NEVER STOP REACHING FOR
GREATNESS.
>> Kimberly: MEANWHILE, THE
PRESIDENT IS LEAVING THE
DOOR OPEN TO RESCHEDULING
THE CANCELLED SUMMIT WITH
NORTH KOREA'S KIM JONG UN.
THIS AFTER THE ROGUE REGIME
SAYS THEY ARE STILL WILLING
TO MEET WITH TRUMP AT THIS
POINT IN TIME.
>>
AT ANY
TIME.
>> WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE ARE TALKING TO THEM NOW.
IT WAS A VERY NICE STATEMENT
THEY PUT OUT.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IT COULD EVEN BE THE 12TH.
WE ARE TALKING TO THEM NOW.
THEY VERY MUCH WANT TO DO
IT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO DO IT.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> Kimberly: OKAY, GREG.
SO GIVING A ROUSING SPEECH.
WERE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT?
YOU SEEM STUNNED.
>> Greg: TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT I SHOULD TALK ABOUT
NORTH KOREA OR THE AMAZING
COMMENCEMENT SPEECH.
A COMMENCEMENT SPEECH FOR
THE REST OF AMERICA.
HE IS SPEAKING A LANGUAGE
THAT EVERYONE AROUND THE
WORLD UNDERSTANDS, INCLUDING
OUR ADVERSARIES.
SO WHEN HE SAYS STUFF THAT
IS CONVEYING AMERICA FIRST
AND WE'RE BACK AND WE'RE
GREAT, IT'S KIND OF MEANT
FOR RUSSIA.
IT'S MEANT FOR CHINA.
IT'S MEANT FOR NORTH KOREA.
IT'S MEANT FOR EVERYBODY WHO
ACTUALLY UNDERSTANDS IT.
I KNOW IT WORKS BECAUSE IT
UPSETS THE ELITES WHO
PREFER, YOU KNOW, THE VLACID
LEXICON OF THE POLITICAL
PLATITUDES THAT HE DOESN'T
TRAFFIC IN.
SO I THINK THE REST OF THE
WORLD GETS IT.
EVEN IF MORNING JOE DOESN'T
HE HAS HIJACKED THE BULL
HORN.
BEFORE, HOLLYWOOD WAS WHAT
TRANSMITTED OUR VALUES
AROUND THE WORLD.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE HE HAS
TAKEN THE BULL HORN AND SAYS
NO, MY TURN.
>> Kimberly: OKAY.
THERE YOU GO.
GUTFELD SHOW GETS IT SUNDAY
SHOW GETS IT JUST NOT
MORNING JOE.
>> Kimberly: AMERICA FIRST.
VERY WELL RECEIVED VETS.
>> Jesse: VERY WELL
RECEIVED.
HE SPENT HOURS AFTERWARDS
SHAKING HANDS WITH ALL THE
CADETS.
HE LOVES THESE PEOPLE IN
UNIFORM.
HE HAS A SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE U.S.
MILITARY.
HE IS FUNDING THEM TO
HEIGHTS THAT WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE TO BUILD FASTER
PLANES AND FASTER SHIPS AND
MORE MASSIVE NUCLEAR
WARHEADS, JUAN.
SO, THE AMERICAN MILITARY IS
BACK.
HE RECOGNIZES IT.
IT'S NICE FOR THE COUNTRY TO
SEE A PRESIDENT WHO
100 PERCENT SUPPORTS THE MEN
AND WOMEN IN THE MILITARY.
AND HE SAID SOMETHING WHICH
IS VERY SMART.
YOU WANT TO BUILD THE
MILITARY UP TO STRONGLY THAT
YOU NEVER HAVE TO USE IT AND
I THINK THAT'S THE MESSAGE
THERE.
WHEN IT COMES TO NORTH
KOREA, IT'S CLASSIC LIKE YOU
SAID YESTERDAY, ART OF THE
DEAL.
HE IS MOVING.
HE IS SHAKING.
IS HE ZIGGING AND ZAGGING.
THE WHOLE TIME THE PEANUT
GALLERY IS TRYING TO THROW
SPIT BALLS AT HIM.
WAIT 24 HOURS AND NORTH
KOREA COMES BEGGING BACK TO
THE TABLE.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE MORE
DESPERATE TO SIT DOWN WITH
THE PRESIDENT THAN IS HE TO
SIT DOWN WITH THEM.
HE CLEARLY HAS THE YOU WERE
HAND AND, LIKE WE SAID, WE
WILL WAIT AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS IN SINGAPORE.
>> Kimberly: THERE YOU GO.
KENNEDY, HELLO.
>> HI THERE.
IT'S A REALLY FUNNY CONTRAST
WITH HILLARY CLINTON.
THESE ARE TOO VASTLY
DIFFERENT SPEECHES.
THIS MAY BE THE ONLY HIGH
PROFILE SPEECH A
CONSERVATIVE GIVES AT A
COLLEGE COMMENCEMENT THIS
YEAR.
AND, OF COURSE, AT THE
MILITARY ACADEMY ANNAPOLIS
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING
TO BE HECKLED.
AND THAT ALSO HAS TO BE
REFRESHING.
IT IS A HAND-PICKED VENUE
AND RECEPTIVE AUDIENCE.
BUT THESE SPEECHES ARE SO
DIFFERENT BECAUSE HILLARY
CLINTON JUST A WEEK AGO AT
YALE WAS SCREECHING TO A
VERY BORED AUDIENCE I'M
STILL NOT OVER IT AND THE
PRESIDENT IS ABLE TO GIVE A
MORE FORWARD-LOOKING SPEECH,
WHETHER OR NOT YOU AGREE
WITH SOME OF THE PRINCIPLES
THAT HE ADDRESSES AND TALKS
ABOUT.
AND, YES, YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
INSTEAD OF TALKING ABOUT
HIMSELF AND A PAINFUL LOSS
AND RELIVING GROUNDHOG DAY
EVERY SINGLE DAY, HE IS
TELEGRAPHING TO NORTH KOREA
AND RUSSIA AND CHINA AND
ALSO GETS TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HIS AGENDA.
SO, YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T THINK
WE WERE GOING TO BE TALKING
AT ALL THIS YEAR ABOUT
COMMENCEMENT SPEECH THAT
WASN'T COMPLETELY BUBBLE
WRAPPED AND GROUP THINK.
FOR THAT IT IS SOMEWHAT
REFRESHING.
>> Kimberly: A LOT OF PEOPLE
ENJOYED THIS ONE.
I HOPE YOU DID, TOO.
>> Juan: INTERESTING TO ME
COME AND LISTEN TO YOU GUYS
A COUPLE PROTESTERS.
I DON'T THINK A WHOLE LOT.
>> Jesse: THOSE ARE FOR YOU,
JUAN.
>> Juan: INSIDE THE KIDS
WERE PRETTY RESPECTFUL.
INSIDE YOU CALL IT ROUSING.
I'M INTERESTED.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS SPEECH
WAS ABOUT AMERICA FIRST.
IT WAS WRAPPED IN
PATRIOTISM.
HE WRAPPED HIMSELF IN THE
FLAG.
MILITARY.
I THINK THAT'S, JESSE, WHY
HE SPENT TIME.
HE WANTS THEM AND THEIR
STAMP OF APPROVAL AND THEIR
HIGH APPROVAL RATINGS AMONG
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
TRANSFER TO HIM.
BUT, WHEN YOU THINK.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK IS HE
GIVING A ROUSING PATRIOTIC
SPEECH BECAUSE HE WANTS TO
BOOST HIS APPROVAL RATING?
>> Juan: YES.
>> Kimberly: THROUGH THE
CADETS?
>> Juan: LET'S LOOK AT THE
SUBSTANCE OF IT.
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT OH,
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THE
MILITARY STRONGER AND ALL
THAT WAIT A MINUTE, OUR
MILITARY IS THE STRONGEST IN
THE WORLD.
>> Jesse: WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE IT EVEN STRONGER,
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT?
>> Kimberly: REBUILDING IT.
>> Juan: SUGGESTING SOMEBODY
DIDN'T BELIEVE IN THEM.
MILITARY.
OBAMA, BUSH, CLINTON?
>> Kimberly: IT WAS UNDER
FUND YOU
FUNDEDOU
FUNDED.U
UNDER FUNDED UNDER OBAMA.
>> Juan: THAT IS ECHO IN THE
CONSERVATIVE CHAMBER.
THE FACT IS WE HAVE A
MILITARY THAT SUNDAY IFED
AT -- I THINK THE TOP 20
OTHER MILITARIES IN THE
WORLD DON'T HAVE AS MUCH
FUNDING AS OUR MILITARY.
>> Kennedy: CAN I JUST SAY
THIS?
JUAN, LET ME ME AGREE WITH
YOU ON SOMETHING.
I DO THINK WE SPEND AN AWFUL
LOT OF MONEY ON THE
MILITARY.
I THINK WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
RESPONSIBLE STEWARDSHIP
THERE ARE WAYS THAT WE COULD
LOOK AT CUTTING COSTS IN THE
MILITARY WITHOUT MAKING OUR
COUNTRY LESS SAFE AND
WITHOUT COMPROMISING OUR
PATRIOTISM AND THE DEBT OF
GRATITUDE THAT WE OWE TO MEN
AND WOMEN WHO WEAR THE
UNIFORM.
BUT, ALSO, BEING SUPPORTIVE
OF THE MILITARY DOESN'T JUST
MEAN WRITING THEM A BLANK
CHECK.
>> Juan: I AGREE.
>> Greg: CAN I JUST RESPOND?
JUAN, WHEN YOU QUESTION
SOMEBODY'S PATRIOTISM.
THAT MEANS YOU CAN READ
THEIR MIND.
IF SOMEBODY IS ACTUALLY
EXPRESSING A LOVE FOR A
COUNTRY, CAN YOU SAY OH,
THAT'S JUST -- HE IS TRYING
TO PLAY TO THIS AUDIENCE.
YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
IT'S NOT AN ARGUMENT TO
SAY -- YOU CLAIM YOU CAN
READ HIS MIND.
>> Juan: DID I NOT.
>> YEAH, YOU DID.
YOU BASICALLY SAID IT WAS
ALL AN APP. HE WAS WRAPPING
HIMSELF IN THE FLAG.
MAYBE HE LOVES AMERICA.
BUT YOU ARE RIDING HIS MIND
WHEN YOU ARE SAYING OH, HE
IS WRAPPING YOUR --
BASICALLY SAYING I KNOW WHAT
HE IS REALLY DOING.
JUAN JAWNEL I LISTENED TO
THE SPEECH.
THE MAN IS TALKING AMERICA
FIRST.
>> Kimberly: WHAT'S WRONG
WITH THAT.
>> Juan: NO MORE APOLOGIES,
WE ARE GOING TO LOOK AT
AMERICA FIRST.
HOW IS THIS LOOKED AT AROUND
THE WORLD IT'S NOT MIND
READING IT'S LISTENING.
WHAT HE SAID WALLS.
>> Greg: YOU ARE
INTERPRETING.
>> Juan: LET ME SPEAK FOR A
SECOND.
GUT DIVUT FOR A
>>T DIVUT FOR A
>> GDIVUT FOR A
>> GreVUT FOR A
>> Greg:T FOR A
>> Greg: FFOR A
>> Greg: FORR A
>> Greg: FOR AA
>> Greg: FOR A SECOND.
>> Juan: WHAT DOES THE REST
OF THE WORLD HEAR AMERICA NO
LONGER AS THE GLOBAL LEADER
IS HE RETRENCHING AND
PULLING BACK AND SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK OUT FOR
AMERICA FIRST.
AMERICA IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
WORLD LEADER.
>> Kimberly: HE IS THE
PRESIDENT THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
>> Juan: YES.
>> Kimberly: HE IS NOT
PRESIDENT OF NORTH KOREA.
>> Juan: NO, WE ARE INVOLVED
THERE BECAUSE WE HAVE
INTEREST IN ASIA.
>> Kimberly: WHY CAN'T HE
LOOK AT AMERICA FIRST WHAT
CAN I DO TO IMPROVE THE MEN
AND WOMEN OF THE MILITARY
THAT SERVE VALIANTLY BY
MAKING SURE THEY ARE TAKEN
CARE OF, BY MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE V.A.?
LOOKING INWARD TO BE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT THINGS AND MAKE
IT BETTER FOR EVERYBODY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, MAKE US
STRONGER AND BETTER AS A
NATION.
CONTEND KENNEDY ISN'T THAT
ONE THE ARGUMENTS OF THE
ANTIWAR LEFT THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS EMBRACED THAT WE
HAVE SPENT SO MUCH MONEY
OVERSEAS.
WE HAVE NEEDLESSLY SPENT
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
WHY SHOULDN'T WOULD HE BE
INVESTING IT HERE?
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU
WOULD HEAR ELIZABETH WARREN
OR BERNIE SANDERS SAY.
>> Juan: I AGREE.
>> Kennedy: THE PRESIDENT IS
ESSENTIALLY SAYING YOU CAN'T
HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
>> Juan: WHAT HE IS SAYING
TO THE WORLD IS, I'M GOING
TO PULL OUT OF AGREEMENTS
LIKE THE IRAN DEAL OR THE
CLIMATE DEAL.
ASIA DEAL IN TERMS OF
MARKETS.
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO
RENEGOTIATE.
I'M A DEALMAKER.
AND I'M GOING TO CREATE SOME
CHAOS HERE.
WHAT DOES THE REST OF THE
WORLD HEAR?
GEE, YOU ARE NO LONGER PART
OF OUR EFFORT AND THE UNITED
STATES IS
STATES IS CEDING IT'S ROLE.
IF YOU WANT TO BE LAST.
>> Juan: I'M NOT SAYING
THAT.
>> Jesse: WE HAVE NOT LEFT
OUR ALLIES BEHIND WE JUST
RALLIED A COALITION IN ASIA
AND COALITION IN SYRIA.
JUST GOT UNANIMOUS COUNCIL
SUPPORT FOR THE U.N. OVER IN
NORTH KOREA THERE IS A LOFT
THINGS WE ARE DOING LEADING
THE WORLD INSTEAD OF GOING
ALONG TO GET ALONG LIKE
OTHER PRESIDENTS.
>> Juan: LIKE PRINTING COINS
LIKE TRUMP AND KIM ON THEM?
>> Jesse: IS HE A BIG
INVESTOR.
>> Juan: ARE YOU BUYING THEM
>> Greg: BROUGHT UP TWO
DEALS CORRECT DECISION
CLIMATE DEAL WOULD HAVE COST
100 TRILLION OVER A CENTURY.
GOOD TO PULL OUT OF THAT
IRAN, WE KNOW BEN RHODES WAS
SO BAD HE HAD TO LIE ABOUT
THIS DEAL TO AMERICA.
WE NOW KNOW IT'S BAD.
THIRD THING GOING ON RIGHT
NOW IS NORTH KOREA.
PEOPLE ARE ACTING LIKE OH MY
GOD, THIS IS SHOCKING.
THIS IS SHOCKING THAT HE
CANCELLED.
FIRST, YOU MUST BE SHOCKED
BY THE SUNRISE.
THIS IS HOW NEGOTIATIONS GO.
AND WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME
IS SEEING THE MEDIA KIND OF
HAPPY IF WORLD PEACE MIGHT
HIT A SNAG BECAUSE THEY
DISLIKE TRUMP SO MUCH.
TO THEM TRUMP IS NOT A
PRESIDENT.
HE IS -- NO, HE IS YOUR
EXTHAT YOU ARE BETTER ABOUT.
IF YOUR EX DISCOVERS A CURE
TO A DISEASE YOU CAN'T BE
HAPPY BECAUSE IS HE YOUR EX.
>> Kimberly: THAT'S CHILD
OISH.
CAN'T DO THAT YOU HAVE TO BE
HAPPY WHEN THE DISEASE IS
CURED.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> Kimberly: JESSE, ONE MORE
THING NOW?
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT OBAMA
LEFT THE IRAQIS BEHIND.
HE LEFT THE UKRAINIANS
BEHIND AND THE ISRAELIS
BEHIND.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
ALLIANCES.
>> Juan: DID YOU NOTICE WHO
JUST WON THE ELECTION IN
IRAQ?
>> WHAT ABOUT LIBYA?
>> Juan: ANTI-AMERICAN
CLERIC.
HOW ABOUT THAT?